joining us now is brandon jett president
of the national border patrol council
brandon good to see you this friday
afternoon before we get into it
i want to put up this graphic on the
screen so people can take a look at the
trend lines here you see the gray line
in this shows a typical seasonal decline
over the summer in 2018 the orange line
uh there shows a huge decline oh sorry
they've changed the colors of the lines
uh so the blue line there shows 2019
where we had a big spike
and then it went down when the trump
administration
implemented its border policies that red
line at the bottom
bit of an anomaly because there was
covid but take
a look at the 2021
line and that's actually not up to date
and i apologize
for that but that green line is showing
that the numbers are spiking we're
expecting
some 210 000 people have crossed the
border in july
your thoughts about what we're seeing
as long as this administration continues
to make border security a political
issue
as long as they continue to talk about
root causes that exist in other
countries
instead of dealing with the root causes
right here in the united states
we're going to continue to see these
numbers rise as long as we reward
illegal activity as long as we continue
to release people
into the united states under the catch
and release program we can expect these
numbers to continue to rise
and that's why we're seeing it even in
the brutal
months where where the heat is just
absolutely staggering we're going to
continue to see this trend go
up 834 unaccompanied minors
in a single day this despite the fact
that the biden administration is sending
out
all of these messages to the northern
triangle countries oh don't come or at
least don't come now
nobody's south of the border brandon is
listening
no because actions speak speak louder
than words you can tell somebody don't
do anything
or we're going to do this but if you
don't follow through with that if you
continue to reward
again criminality is being rewarded on
the border
if your actions don't match what you're
telling people people are going to
continue to violate the law they're
going to come
knowing that they're going to get
they're ultimately going to get released
into the united states which is what
they wanted in the first place
let's talk about the health implications
of these border crossings because in the
last week in mcallen texas alone
some 1700 people or 1500 people rather
who were coveted positive were released
into the community the biden white house
doesn't have a plan yet it says it's
working on one and all the time
the dhs secretary mayorkus is saying the
border is closed the border is closed
i i don't know if he's gaslighting
people or if he really believes the
border is closed
no he knows that the border isn't closed
what they're trying to do is they're
trying to deflect they're trying to
reach to their base trying to get their
base general
genera knowing that they're trying to do
what they want them to do
but in reality that 1700 people that's
what we know of
we're releasing thousands of people
every single week
most of these people aren't being tested
for covid or they're being tested by
ngos and the ngos
are not reporting back who these people
are so we can't do contact tracing
we just don't know what's coming into
the united states we don't know how many
people are coming in with covet
and we don't know how many people that
were releasing into our communities
that could affect united states citizens
what in reality
this administration is taking care of
illegal border crossers
more than they are un united states
citizens well one thing for sure
since javier vela lobos took over there
in mcallen texas a republican
mayor we're hearing a lot more about
this and he's certainly letting the
administration know how he feels brandon
judd
it's great to catch up with you thanks
for giving us the latest on this
appreciate it